et sur les chaînes et après pour la la
formule mathématique en fait de
contrastes
alors l'idée de nation collaboration
l'avion et il approche avec les élèves
est intéressante puisque on leur dit bon
voilà on parfois on va se parler dry est
ce qu'on a le droit qu'est ce que fait
google
devaux de vos coordonnées personnelles
avec ses valeurs usées
quoi
[Musique]
et
on sait faire mais on n'a peut-être pas
toutes les compétences pour le faire au
mieux on va dire on peut là encore font
tant de points de vie avec des prof
d'informatique par exemple on peut
améliorer ce qu'on fait
pour discussion que
follis et on va dire voilà l'école se
doit d'être dans son époque
à ce titre-là d'utiliser et de réaliser
les apprentissages haut et par le
numérique au numérique parce qu'on doit
on se doit par exemple d'éduquer les
élèves à la bonne utilisation d'internet
par exemple mais également
profitez des avantages du numérique pour
améliorer les apprentissages